always be independent we go our own path
we'll always try and get to the bottom
of everything and tell you the truth but
let not your heart be troubled because
laura
ingram is there bama won
roll tide that was hannity the best
political um uh night of
crazy news combined with the best
political i mean the best athletic night
for college football okay i almost
botched that but you know what i'm
saying
nick saban i mean you got to give this
guy credit this guy just wins
i don't he kills it all i i think the
republican party should take some
lessons from saban okay
first of all he doesn't accept
mediocrity he has a great relationship
with his players he loves his players
and he just even if they win
if they didn't do it right he wants him
to do it again and again and again so he
doesn't accept mediocrity and he wins he
doesn't care that people hate him
because
he's beautiful i mean he's beautiful
because he wins so he just keeps going
i love saving him but but
yeah it's beautiful because he wins they
don't like him because he wins a lot
some people don't like him
but he doesn't care about that i'm sure
no one cares about my my football views
so i guess i'm going to stop right now
but if you're in
our business you really can't care if
people like you or not it's amazing how
other people are so upset if they get
criticized
now sean you and i have if you and i
were caring about what people thought of
us we would have
melted away many years ago i think we've
crossed that
that boundary a lot i don't know when
the switch went off but it's been a long
time exactly i just don't care awesome
show tonight sean great
have a great show